hello everyone
it's no secret that the vast bulk of
internet usage is vulnerable to hacking
whether it's through hazardous messaging
apps or faulty operating systems
penetration testing has become the norm
for vulnerability assessment in order to
fill this vacuum in digital security
kali linux is a well-known operating
system in this fight against hackers
kali linux a distribution designed
specifically for penetration testers has
layers of features that we will go over
in today's lesson and take a look at
some of the tools and features that the
operating system has to offer
let's take a look at the videos topics
and features that the operating system
has to offer
let's take a look at the videos topics
we start by learning the requirements of
an operating system like kali linux
we learn more about the core features of
the os and its intricacies
moving on we take a look at the five
distinct stages of penetration testing
that dictate the flow of vulnerability
assessment in general
next we learn about some important tools
that can be found on kali linux which
are geared specifically for ethical
hacking purposes
and finally we have an extensive
demonstration where we work on some
basic terminal commands proxy tools and
a couple of highly regarded software
from the crux of the operating system
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
let's start by learning why one should
learn kali linux in the first place
in today's world in organizations most
valuable asset is its information or
data
this is true for all kinds of businesses
be it public or private on a daily basis
they all deal with enormous amounts of
sensitive information
as a consequence terrorist groups
hacking teams and cyber thieves often
attack them
to ensure the safety and protection
businesses use a variety of security
measures and regularly upgrade their
index
organizations must be proactive in this
age of digitalization by regularly
assessing and updating their security
everyday hackers discover new methods to
breach firewalls
ethical hackers or white hat hackers
provide a fresh perspective on security
they conduct penetration tests to
validate security measures
generally they will penetrate your
networks and give you relevant
information about your security posture
once an organization has this knowledge
it may upgrade its security procedures
accordingly
the latest version of kali linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed
after reviewing every tool that was
included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work
or which duplicated other tools that
provided the same or similar
functionality
occasionally when conducting penetration
testing or hacking we must automate our
activities since there may be hundreds
of conditions and pillows to test and
manually examining everything is time
consuming
to improve our productivity we utilize
tools that come pre-packaged with kali
linux these tools not only save us time
but also accurately capture and process
the data
the kali linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets greatly reduces
the risk of source contamination
although penetration tools tend to be
written in english the developers have
ensured that kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need to do for the
job
since arm based single board systems
like the raspberry pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
kali linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with a mainline distribution
so tools for arm are updated in
conjunction with the rest of the
distribution tools
now that we understand the necessity for
an operating system like linux let us
take a look at some of its core features
and offerings to the ethical hacking
world
kali linux formerly known as backtrack
linux is an open source linux
distribution which is aimed at advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools
targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
kali linux is a multi-platform solution
accessible and freely available to
information security professionals and
hobbyists
among all the linux distributions kali
linux takes its route from the debian
operating system
debian has been a highly dependable and
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong foundation
to the kali linux desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of kali linux come disable by
default
this is done to prevent any external
factors from affecting the installation
procedure which may pose a risk in
critical environments
apart from boosting security it allows a
deeper element of security and control
to the most enthusiastic of users
let us now take a look at the five
stages or phases of penetration
testing this is the first stage of the
penetration test which is known as the
reconnaissance phase
in this stage the security researcher
collects information about the target it
can be done actively which means you are
collecting information without
contacting the target or even both
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
network components active machines open
ports and access points operating system
details etc
this activity can be performed by using
information available in the public
domain and using different tools
the next phase is more tool oriented
rather than perform manually and it is
the scanning phase
the penetration tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the target the penetration tester
runs one or more scanner tools to gather
information about the target
by using various scanners such as war
dialers port scanners network mappers
and vulnerability scanners the tester
collects as many vulnerabilities which
help to turn attack in a more
sophisticated way
the next stage is known as the gaining
access phase
in this phase the penetration tester
tries to establish a connection with the
target and exploit the vulnerabilities
found in the previous stage
exploitation may be buffer overflow
attacks denial of service or dos attacks
session hijacking and many more
basically penetration tester extracts
information and sensitive data from
servers by gaining access using
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
back door for himself
it helps him to identify hidden
vulnerabilities in the system and can
later act as a gateway to retrieve
control of the system
in the final phase of covering tracks
the penetration tester tries to remove
all logs and footprints which help the
administrator identify his presence
this helps the tester to think like a
hacker and perform corrective actions to
mitigate those activities
now that we understand the basics of
penetration testing and how ethical
hackers go about the way
let us take a look at some notable tools
which can be used on kali linux
at the top of the chain lies nmap
nmap is a free and open source utility
port scanner which can be used for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hacker to
leverage any insecure openings and
breach the device
it's a part of the scanning phase of the
penetration testing
nmap uses raw ip packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what services these hosts
are offering what operating systems they
are running and their versions what type
of packet filters and firewalls are in
use and dozens of other characteristics
it was designed to rapidly scan large
networks but works fine against single
hosts as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on the list we have metasploit
the metasploit framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe systemic vulnerabilities on
networks and servers
as a part of the third stage of
penetration testing it's an open source
framework which can be easily customized
and used with most operating systems
with metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use a ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots
as another flavor of threat hunting once
these flaws are identified and
documented the information can be used
to address systemic weaknesses and
prioritize solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the exploit is fed into
the system there are a host of options
for the hacker
depending on the vulnerability hackers
can even run root commands from the
terminal allowing complete control over
the activities of the compromised system
as well as all personal data stored on
the device
a big advantage of metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on a
target system thereby giving a detailed
picture of the security index of said
system
this also provides the necessary
exploits that can be used to bypass the
firewalls and the antivirus software
having a single solution to gather
almost all the necessary points of
attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by the high rank in this list
at number 3 we have wireshark
wireshark is the world's foremost and
widely used networking protocol analyzer
it lets you see what happening on your
network at a microscopic level and is a
de facto standard across many commercial
and non-profit enterprises government
agencies and educational institutions
wireshark is a popular open source tool
to capture network packets and converts
them to human readable binary format it
provides every single detail of the
organization's network infrastructure
it consists of devices designed to help
measure the ins and outs of the network
the information collected to wireshark
can be used for various purposes such as
real time or offline network analysis
identification of the traffic coming
onto your network its frequency and its
latency between specific hops
this helps network administrators
generate statistics based on real-time
data
wireshark is also a cross-platform tool
that can be installed on windows linux
and mac systems to enable hackers in all
ecosystems to monitor network traffic
irrespective of the operating system
the development team is determined to
maintain this level of freedom for their
users in the foreseeable future
the next tool on our list is air garden
which is a part of the third phase of
penetration testing
this is a multi-use bash script for
linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday wi-fi router
and its counterparts
along with being able to launch denial
of service attacks on compromised
networks this multi-purpose wi-fi
hacking tool has very rich features
which support multiple methods for wi-fi
hacking including multiple wps hacking
modes all-in-one wep attack handshake
file capturing evil twin attacks pixie
dust and so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
wireless traffic traversing the air
channels
to its open source nature
air garden can be used with multiple
community plugins and add-ons thereby
increasing its effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz band and 5 gigahertz band
the next tool is john the ripper
john the ripper is an open source
password security auditing and password
recovery tool available for many
operating systems
john the ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and cipher types including for
use of passwords of operating systems
web apps groupware database servers
network traffic captures encrypted
private keys file systems and document
files some of the key features of the
tool include offering multiple modes to
speed up password tracking automatically
detecting the hashing algorithm used by
the passwords and the ease of running
and configuring the tool making it a
password tracking script of choice for
novices and professionals alike
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word list being used in this
dictionary attacks can be used from the
user's end allowing for a completely
customizable process
now that we have covered the basics of
kali linux let us take a look at the
agenda for our demo today
we start out with a few terminal
commands that are a basic part of a
linux operating system
configure our own proxy chains to
maintain anonymity while running
penetration testing attacks on our
victims
next we run a few nmap scans on a local
windows 10 machine to find out the type
of information that can be gathered in
such a scenario
moving on we use wireshark to monitor
internet traffic and understand the
importance of encryption and security
when browsing the world wide web
next we learn about metasploit and its
various applications and the line of
vulnerability assessment of a device and
finally we use matters ploy to take root
access of a fully updated windows 10
computer system
let's begin with some terminal basics on
kali linux
when most people hear the term linux
they envision a complex operating system
used only by programmers however the
experience is not as frightening as it
appears linux is an umbrella term for a
collection of free and open source unix
operating systems
there are many variants like ubuntu
fedora debian
these are distributions which will be a
more precise term
when using a linux operating system you
will most likely utilize a shell which
is a command line interface that
provides access to the operating system
services the majority of linux
distributions ship with a graphical user
interface also known as gui as their
primary shell this is done to facilitate
user interaction in the first place
having said that a command line
interface is suggested due to its
increased power and effectiveness by
entering the commands into the cli tasks
that require a multi-step gui procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
we can start the terminal by clicking on
the prompt icon here on top
once the terminal is open
we can put up our commands the first
command that we are going to look into
is pwd
pwd stands for present working directory
as of right now what you are seeing is
the terminal window by default if i
write pwd and press enter
this shows the directory in which the
terminal is being run on as of right now
it's in the nf folder
of my desktop which is specifically this
folder if i open up this folder you can
see it is currently empty as in it has
no contents
if i
use another command known as mkdir which
is supposed to stand for make directory
and i write nf2 shortage for
new folder too
if i open up the nf
you can see the new folder is created
this is how the pwd command works
another important command
to change directories it's called the cd
command let's say right now if i am in
nf i want to create a new file in an f2
folder or something else in the nf2
folder i have to shift to cd and f2
now if i write pwd
it will show the present working
directory of home simply learn desktop
nf and inside that i am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate to the linux
files and this directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this
for now cd works another few commands is
we can write cd
dot dot
and it will come back one folder now the
pwd will be just nf and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go
a different file let's say if we just go
for cd
home
simpler
that's it
right now these are the folders in our
current present working directory
we have the desktop the documents
downloads etc
from here we can again go to the desktop
using the same cd command
cross check the
changing of directories
and check the files again and yes there
we go nf how do we know this what are
the command that we are used to show the
files and folders that folder is known
as the ls command ls can be used to view
the contents of a directory by default
this command will display the contents
of your current working directory if we
add some other parameters we can find
the contents of other directories as
well
there are some hidden files as well in
linux which cannot be showed just with
ls for example if you just go to cd etc
which is a configuration folder for
linux
if you write ls now these are the files
that can be seen
if we want to see the hidden files we'll
have to add one more parameter here like
ls minus a and as you can see the number
of files have increased this time around
there are other things as well that we
can see with linux
ls minus al will show the hidden files
along with some of the parameters and
some of the permissions that has been
provided for each file
as you can see many of these files have
root access some of them can write some
of them can read
it differs file to file and the ls minus
al command is used to check each of
these files permission and change them
accordingly if needed
the next command that we can look for
is the cat command or concatenate
it is one of the most frequently used
commands and it is used to list the
contents of a file on the output
for example
let's say if i have a file
at the desktop
in this nf2 folder i will create a
document
create an empty file
e5
i'll open up the document
and i'll write it as
hello kali
i will save this up
now to change the directories from etc
to nf2 we have already discussed how to
use the cd command using just the folder
name now if we want to go to the entire
directory
we can write
siri
home
as you can see it is already prompting
us to complete the
name of the directory at this point we
just have to press tab
and it completes it for ourselves
next we already know we have to enter
the desktop
nf and nf2
and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press ls
we can find a file over here now as
discussed for the concatenate it is used
to show the contents of a file so right
now if we press c80 which stands for
concatenate
e file
as you can see we have written hello
kali in the text file and we can see the
output right now
we can also use it to create new files
for example if we write cat
any file name such as e file 2
here we can write anything
hello kali
again
once we press ctrl c here
we can check e file 2
and we have hello kali again printed
over here we can see the same using the
concatenate command as well
if i press ls you can see we have two
files here
and i can go with cat
e file 2
and i have hello kali again this is how
the concatenate command works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
cp which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mind to this is not
moving this is only going to copy the
command for example currently our pwd
which is the present working directory
is in the nf2 folder as you can see over
here
let's copy the e file to to the nf
folder
we can write cp
e file 2
and give the path of the nf folder which
will be home
simply learn
desktop
nnf
now if i press ls i will find both the
files in nf2 since i
copied to go back to the nf folder again
we can again use the same command of
no no we can again use the home
simply learn
desktop
and just nf no nf2 this time just enough
as you can see this will change back our
present working directory now when we
press ls
we will find the e file to file and the
nf2 folder and we can confirm this using
the gui as well
this is the nf folder and you can see
the nf2 folder and the e file to
document if i write cat e file 2
cat e file 2. we can see the contents of
the file now this can be done using
moving as well for example if i go to
cdnf2 which is the inside folder it has
both the
document files like e file and e file 2.
let's say i want to move the e file
completely from nf2 to nf1 instead of
writing cp the command i'm going to use
is mv
mve file and again give the path of the
folder into which i have to copy which
will be again home
simply learn
desktop
and nf
as you can see the contents of the nf2
have appeared here and e file has been
moved
from nf2 to
nf
this is this nf2 and we don't find e
file here anymore if we press cd dot dot
and we go back to nf ls right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and e file to that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple one line
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using gui this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for linux
operating systems
another very important
command for linux operating system is
the sudo command sudo is short for super
user do the command enables you to
perform tasks that require
administrative or root permissions we
can think of it as how we run programs
as administrator on windows systems it
is not advisable to use this card for
daily use because it might be easy for
an error to occur and the permissions of
root are very intricate
so new beginners are
advised to use the sudo command only
when absolutely necessary for example
sudo su
with this command i am giving this
terminal
a root permission
this su stands for this user
at this point it's going to ask for my
admin password
once i enter my password
and i now have root access
note how the password that i entered did
not show up here this is a security
measure to prevent people from snooping
on your root password which is the end
game of all this operating system
as you also can see the symbol changed
if the dollar symbol is showing its
source as a standard user when you
switch to root you can easily see a hash
symbol
this opens up a separate shell inside
this terminal command for example we can
exit out of the root user to the
standard user using the command exit and
once again we have the dollar sign and
the root has vanished over here there
are some commands that will only work
with administrative access for example
when updating the kali linux system we
have to use apt update
as you can see it says problem unlinking
the file because permission denied
now let's try this using sudo
sudo
apt update
as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the system
this can be done using either writing
the sudo command every time we want to
perform a root access or we can just
write sudo su once and write apt update
alone
the fetching is complete over here
for the second example let's say i just
write sudo su and this time is not going
to ask me the password because at this
current terminal process i've already
provided the rules password once and it
is in memory right now
now
when we use to update the system we had
to write sudo apt update that was
because we were running it as a standard
user now we are running it as a root
user so all we have to write is apd
update and it's going to continue its
work
there you go
another command that can be useful is
the ping command
it's pretty self-explanatory it's going
to be checking the internet connectivity
it can be used to check internet
connectivity or you can see if the there
is a local server on your system which
needs to be pinged then you can check
that for example if we have to write
ping and we can use either ip address or
domain let's say if we want to check
that if we can access google.com using
this kali linux installation or not we
can write ping google.com
and you can see it shows the bytes being
sent and received and how much time it
took to take up the request
this can be done for local systems as
well for example this installation of
kali linux is being run on a virtual
machine
once this machine is running i still
have my
whole host machine running over here the
ip address of which is 192.168.29
179.
if i try to ping this from here
as you can see the time to complete the
request is drastically low compared to a
website on the internet considering this
is on the local network this is how the
ping command is worked and it can show
you what kind of packages are
transmitted how many are received if
there was any kind of packet loss
between the connection window and other
details
a very important command when working
with the terminal for long duration is
the history command
pretty self-explanatory there are so
many commands that are being run
sometimes people forget what was the
change they did oh
what was the directory name they put a
history command helps to recover some of
the commands that we have written it
doesn't go all the way back but it takes
up many commands that were inputted in
the last few processes
this is how the history command works
these are some of the most commonly used
terminal commands if you want to learn
more about this terminal and every other
feature of this please let us know in
the comment section and we'll try to
make an in-depth tutorial special if you
could
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on linux
moving on we learn how to configure
proxy chains on our system
proxying refers to the technique of
bouncing your internet traffic through
multiple machines to hide the identity
of the original machine it is a good
tool that hackers use to accomplish this
goal is proxychains
essentially you can use proxychains to
run any program to a proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your ip address proxies even
allows you to use multiple proxies at
once by chaining them together
one of the most important reasons that
proxy chains is used in a security
context is that it's easy to evade
detection
attackers often use proxies to hide
their true identities while executing an
attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located
to see how proxy chain works
let's open firefox first and check our
current ip address
right firefox
and there we go
as we can see firefox is now open
let's check our current ip address right
now
if you go to an address called my
ip.com
and you can see the easily detects our
country is in india and this is a public
ip address
now
if we move to the terminal again
here we can now write
proxy chains
minus h
what this minus h does is it finds a
help it it stands for the help file
this is for help file
what we found out using this is
proxychains has a config file here etc
proxychains4.conf
this is the config file found
using this config file we can customize
how our proxy change should work
if we want to open that we have to use
it in a text editor on windows we have
notepad
and other things like that microsoft
word to edit documents on linux we have
a tool called nano
to access the nano we use the command
nano and give the path of the file that
we want to check
as of right now the proxy change config
file is located over here so we're going
to follow the path there
chains 4
dot conf
and here we go we see the config file
there are three basic types of proxy
chaining here
we have a strict chain where all the
proxy in the list
will be used and they will be chained in
order
we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy chains
will be done by a random combo of
proxies in the proxy list
and your dynamic chain
it's the same as strict chain but dead
proxies are excluded from the chain
and
here we can set up whichever type we
want
to enable or disable a particular type
we use the hash symbol here
as you can see right now all the lines
have a hashtag symbol at the front
except this one a dynamic chain
this is the current one being used let's
say if i want to use a strict chain
method so i can add a hash value here
and remove the hash here at one point of
time
any one of these three four types should
be enabled
let's go for the
dynam um dynamic chain
we can disable this trick chain by
putting the hashtag in front
and removing the dynamic chain as you
can see below we have few commands to
how to handle the nano text editor
this symbol
is known as the control button on your
keyboard now if we want to write out
which is synonymous to saving the file
supposed to go with control o so if i
press ctrl o on my keyboard it says file
name to write and we have to press enter
here since we want to overwrite the
proxychains4.conf file we don't want to
create a new file over here so just
press enter
and we get a permissioned right this
permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this
using a standard user etc is a system
folder to be able to use make some
changes we have to use it using a sudo
command
to exit this nano we have to use the
control x command we use control x
we're going to clear
and this time we're going to use the
sudo command
sudo nano
etc
proxy chains
4 dot conf
and we have the same file open up again
now this time if you want to make a
change let's say we're going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from straight
we're going to use ctrl o for the save
file option
we're going to press enter
and it says root 160 lines
again if you want to reverse this change
we put the hashtag over here
enable dynamic chain
we press ctrl o
press enter and it says root 160 lines
now we can exit straight away using the
control x format
right now we have not provided any file
or a proxy chain we can have proxy ip
addresses from the internet but we have
to make sure that they are safe and they
don't snoop on our data
when there is no proxy change being
provided personally
it going it's going to use the tor
network but for that we have to start
tor
tower is a service in linux
to know more about the store we can
write sudo systemctl which is used to
know the status of services on the linux
operating system
and status of tor
system ctl sorry uh as instead of stl it
should be system ctl status tor as you
can see it is a toss service anonymizing
overlay network for tcp connections and
it's currently inactive now to start
this up
we have to write sudo systemctl
start
dot
now if we repeat the same sudo system
ctl status store
as you can see it's active now
you can see the green logo over here
okay
to integrate the firefox and the browser
we can use the proxy chains command
directly over here we can write proxy
chains
we can use firefox to launch our web
browser and let's say if we want to
visit google.com
we press enter
and the firefox window is launched and
it should open up google.com next
and there we go
if we go to
myip.com once again
as you can see we have a different ip
address and the country is unknown as
well
so this is how we can use proxy chains
to anonymize
internet usage when using kali linux
next on our agenda is the ability to
scan networks using nmap
at its core nmap is a network scanning
tool that uses ip packets to identify
all the devices connected to a network
can learn more about nmap using the help
file
as you can see these are some of the
parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of our system you can see
the version and the url of the webs of
the service
over here
the primary uses of nmap can be broken
into three group processes first the
program gives you detailed information
on every ip active on your network and
then each ipa can then be scanned
secondly it can also be used to
providing a lot of live hosts and open
ports as well as identifying the os of
every connected device
thirdly
nmap has also become a valuable tool for
users looking to protect personal and
business websites
using nmap to scan your own web server
particularly if you're hosting your
website from home is essentially
simulating the process that a hacker
would use to attack your site
attacking your own site in this way is a
powerful way of identifying security
vulnerabilities
as we already discussed the host windows
10 machine on the system has an ip
address a 192 168 29.179
if you want to test the os scan of the
system we're going to first get the root
permission over here
we use the pseudo command and now we are
root user we're going to launch the
command nmap
minus o which is supposed to be an os
detection scan
the ip address we can use of the host
system
192.168.29.179
in a legitimate penetration testing
scenario we can use the ip address of
the
device over here
we are going to let it scan for a while
and it's going to give us some guesses
on what can the os be
as you can see the scan is done and it
has shown some of the ports that are
open
you can see the msrpc port open at the
https 443 port open which is used to
connect to the internet
and it has some aggressive os gases as
well for example it thinks there's a 90
94 chance that it's going to be a
microsoft windows xp service pack 3.
that's partly because a lot of the
windows xp update packages are still
prevalent on windows
now that the os detection is confirmed
there are multiple more
details that we can gather from nmap
let's go with the nmap minus a command
which is supposed to capture as much
data as possible
there is also a speed setting
you can call it a speed setting or a
control setting
of the minus t
minus t ranges from t 0 to t 1 to t
through all the way up to d phi
this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it will take more
time to provide the results but it will
also give a less chance for the
intrusion detection system on the
vulnerable machine firewall to detect
that someone is trying to penetrate the
network for now if we want to go with
somewhat of a high speed we can go with
the t4 and provide the same ip address
of the local machine i am trying to
attack it's going to take a little bit
of time since it's trying to capture a
lot of information
as you can see the results are now here
it launched a scan and took a few top
ports that are most likely vulnerable
from a windows xp perspective and it
showed
a few ports over here it has not shown
991 filtered ports which could not be
attacked anyway since they were closed
for outside access
it shows a few fingerprint settings like
the connection policies and the
port details
it shows an http options some other
intricate details that can be used when
you attacking its servers
it shows a vmware version that it's
running
and some few other ports over here
apart from that we also have the
aggressive os guesses over here just
like we did with the minus o and you can
see this time it is showing windows 7 as
98 percent
no exact os matches since uh if there
was any exact voice matches we could
have seen a hundred percent chances over
here
this is a trace route a trace route will
be the time and the path a connection
request takes from the source to the
destination
for example this request went from
192.168.72.2
to a destination address since this is a
local machine it took only a single step
on multiple occasions if you're trying
to access a remote system it's going to
be a number of tray suits when it jumps
from firewall to firewall and router to
router
this is how we can use nmap to find
information about a system and find some
vulnerable ports we can access
moving on we have a tutorial on how to
use wireshark to sniff network traffic
to start using wireshark we're going to
have to
open the application first
now during installation of wireshark
there is an option to enable if non-root
users can be able to capture traffic or
not
in my installation i have disabled that
so i will be launching wireshark when
using the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
wi-fi adapter
you can see it over here in the vm tab
removable devices
re-link a02.1 and wlan
this is an external wi-fi adapter which
is inserted into my usb system
you can see it over here if i write iw
config
this is the one wlan 0. this is
absolutely necessary because we need to
have a monitor mode
required we won't need it for sniffing
data on wireshark
right now but it's going to be necessary
later on in this tutorial as well as we
will see
for now we can just start up via shark
by writing its name on the command line
and it should start the program
here we go
here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which supposes stand
for ethernet 0 port you can see data is
being transmitted up and down we're
going to select eth0
and we have started capturing data
you can see this uh data request from
the source to destination from the time
and the which protocol it is following
everything we can see and we can see the
ipv4 flags here as well
as you can see over here
to capture internet traffic
we can try running firefox
if we just write wikipedia.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing
okay this is spelling mistake wikipedia
here
you can see the application data of all
these requests going up
and they're connected to a destination
server of one zero through one zero to
one sixty six point two two four
now if we even if we check the
transmission control protocol flags over
here and so many more things
we cannot find anything beneficial as
you can see the information over here is
gibberish which is supposed to be since
it's supposed to be encrypted
now
this is possible due to this being an
https website hence you can see the lock
symbol over here and connection is
supposed to be secure
now what about http ports we have seen
many people recommend to not visit http
ports
repeat
we have seen many people recommend to
not visit http websites and even if we
have to visit to not provide any
critical information
for example let's go to a random
http page over here
as you can see this is
saying connection is not secure and this
is an http http page and not https
now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form let's say i have a
legitimate account over here
if i write my account name
and my password is supposed to be
password one two three four
i press login
and uh the password does not match
because i do not have an account over
here but let's say i did and i was
logged in as expected
we can go to wireshark
we can use filters over here now all the
requests that i am sending it's a tcp
request so i can write a filter
containing tcp
contains
whatever string if it is being passed
let's say for the end username i write
my account name
so i can just write my account name over
here
and press enter
to find a request
over here
now as you can see
there are many flags over here
if we go to the http html form url
encoded and open up some of its flags
as you can see i can see my account name
and simply learn password over here this
is the same
details that i input on the website
let's say i did have a legitimate
account on this website i would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who would be using wireshark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here
this is why it's recommended to not
provide any information on http pages
the security is not up to the mark and
always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or
making any internet transactions or
providing any information
this is how we can use wireshark to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred to the
network adapter
next we have to learn about what is
metasploit
the metasploit project is a computer
security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and aids in penetration
testing and ids development
we can open up the terminal here we're
going to allow root access
and to open up metasploit the keyword is
msf console
it's going to take a little bit of time
to start it up
[Music]
now the metasploit console has been
loaded
from here we can decide what type of
attack we want to launch and what kind
of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets
for example like we already discussed
i'm running this virtual machine on a
windows 10 host machine so if i open the
command prompt from my windows 10 over
here
if i need to check the ip address once i
go with ipconfig
here you can see the ip address of this
local machine
moving on
if we have to attack that machine let's
say we want to see what kind of exploits
are going to work over there
now we already know that windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the hta server
vulnerability hta is supposed to be a
html application but when past the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system
to start off with the metasploit and
accessing such applications
we're going to use
the command
use
exploit and the name of the reverse hta
server is this windows
misc for miscellaneous
hda server
as you can see it already found this one
all right
now there are some options that we need
to set for this exploit to go through
for example you can see some of the
options over here
there's a payload the payload is
supposed to be the malicious file that
we are going to send on the html
application which allows us to give the
back door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a windows
meterpreter reverse tcp
completely understandable now let's set
the l host
l host and r host
and srv host should be the one
where we are going to launch the attack
from for example
if we launched another tab of this
console
and we just press i f config
the ip address is
192.168.72 130.
so we're going to set the lhost as
192.168.72.130
and we're going to do the same thing
with srv host
we're going to set a port
where we need to capture the backdoor
access
next
the payload has already been set
this payload will launch a back door and
give us meter printer access to the
system meterpreter is can be considered
as an upgrade of a normal command prompt
shell
we will look into it once we get the
access in the first place
now that we have set the commands
we can press on exploit and press enter
now
you can see we have a url over here
we're going to copy this url
once the url is copied we take it into
the browser
and paste it
this will ask us to download this file
now as per browser security settings
this file should be blocked by default
we can decide to keep it and with the
correct formulation of this malicious
package even the website browser
antivirus software's will not be able to
detect good payloads we're going to save
this file
and we're going to open it
publisher could not be verified if we
press run
and we go back
to our meetup data access over here
you can see it has already captured a
url fnhd server and it is writing
delivering payload
just have to wait for a few seconds so
the payload is delivered
it has sent
this much amount of data meterpreter
session one is opened
then we should get the access soon
there we go
now
to understand where is the session set
we can write sessions
minus i
as you can see it has a metaphase over
here
we're going to write
sessions minus i
the session id is one so we're going to
write one
and we have the metadata access
now to get a fair idea of the system
we're going to write sysinfo and it's
going to the computer name the os
architecture all these things we can
write the help command to see what are
the things that we can get out of the
system we can take screenshots we can
control the webcam and start a video
chat
we can take a lot of things over here
there are other commands as well where
we can change the file directory like
the cat command cd command there are so
many things that work in the normal cmd
which we can run on the meter beta as
well now if you want to access this
command prompt of the system directly
we can go with this
we have to write shell
and there we go we are in the downloads
folder right now to see if this is the
same computer or not we're going to
write ipconfig
as you can see it is our mesh victim
machine with 192 168 but
29.171
we can just press exit
and we're back with the meter beta
access
this is how we can use meter printer and
metasploit to gain access to a windows
10 machine
next
let's take a look at how we can get root
access from a windows 10 system
we just learned how we can get a
meterpreter access from a system
we can background this meter predator
session by writing background and
pressing enter
we can still we can still see the shares
session is minus i
it's still present over here
now
these kind of access are not
administrative access
these are the kind of backdoors that can
be created for standard users but to get
a complete access of a system including
the program files the windows documents
we need to have her root access or
administrative access
to that we're going to use another
exploit
reminder that the meter bitter session
of the standard access is already
present and we're not messing with it
right now we're going to set up another
session
albeit with the same machine
that exploit name is
use exploit windows
local
bypass uac
event viewer
and there we go
now if we check the options that we can
put in the system we have to choose an
exploit target
we need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
meta with access with the standard user
it doesn't have the system user
we're going to write
set session 1
and we're going to run exploit run a few
commands and it opened a second
meterpreter session
as you can see it is the session 2.
if i write sysinfo
you can still see i'm not the
system user right now i'm still
just
a normal user how can we check that
if you go to shell
it still sees the user generally
downloads all these things
if i press exit
go back to the meter picture there is a
command on meter peter
get system it attempts to elevate your
privilege to that of the local system
which basically means you get promoted
into root access
so if we write get system
and due to pipe impersonation we now
have the system root access
as you can see now it has become x64 and
we are the admin users now if i go to
shell
i can easily go back
windows
and i can easily access these ones
this kind of control over the windows
folders and the
program files folders these kind of
things are not possible if you are not
an admin access or the command prompt
has not been run with admin permissions
this is how we can use privilege
escalation to get into an admin access
system
we use the second
exploit which was the bypass us event
viewer exploit
and essentially used it with the first
session as you can read here windows
escalation usb protection bypass
it was first disclosed on 2016 but it
still works on some systems
this is how we can get root access on a
windows 10 installation
hope you learned something new today if
you have any doubts regarding the topic
mentioned in the lesson
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below
[Music]
you